hello everyone welcome to our session da
3:07 my name is Masood cloud solution
architect at Google and I have joined
here with Abdul lead architect
cybersecurity analytics and tell us we'd
like to talk to you about how we have
built a network anomaly detection
solution to find out layers in net flow
log will focus on four key areas first
how we have simulated production like
volume in a box subtopic secondly a data
flow anomaly detection pipeline to
aggregate data and extract features in a
fixed window
thirdly create a k-means clustering
model using decree ml for train and
normalize data but before we get into
details I'd like to hand it over to
Abdul who is gonna give us a little bit
of context about the problem we are
trying to solve and details about tell
us what do you are do thank you Massoud
hi everyone my name is Abdul Rehman
sitar and I'm the lead architect for
cybersecurity analytics at TELUS I would
also like to acknowledge over here the
support of Jahan scan duranium who's
responsible for cybersecurity analytics
at pillars and is the creator and driver
of the initiatives at Telus associated
with his presentation and Ragland Sinha
Raja who's responsible for cyber
security DevOps at TELUS so a little
about Telus
we are Canada's fastest growing national
telecommunications company with over
thirteen point four million customer
connections across our networks we are a
leader in technology culture and
sustainability and we are committed to
giving where we live and we are the
first Canadian company recognized as the
world's outstanding philanthropic
company cyber security at Telus is led
by a talented 400 strong team protecting
both Tillis and our security customers
innovation is a key value in our team
and we strive to push the boundaries at
the cutting edge of technology so of
late the idea of using big data
analytics for cyber security use-cases
has become prevalent across numerous
industries areas such as smart grids and
scattered systems autonomous connected
vehicles security operation centers
health care systems can benefit from
intersection of big data analytics and
cybersecurity the pinnacle of
collaboration would be prevention of
damage caused by a malicious cyber
security activity due to an
exceptionally accurate prediction of
such activity before it even occurs the
gold or oil that runs the engine of big
data analytics anywhere in any industry
is data no matter how good your advanced
analytics algorithms are unless they've
been enriched this with vast amount of
data that the the results they provide
will not be up to par and this is where
Telus like other organizations who have
access to unique data as a key advantage
we carry the bulk of the nation's
communication data across or across or
across our pipelines we have a
continuous stream of both labeled and
unlabeled data from very diverse data
sources enabling the application of
state-of-the-art advanced analytics
techniques to detect malicious
communications anomalous communication
detection can be used as a first step
for malicious communication detection
and this presentation goes to that first
step and shows how we can use Google's
tech stack to power anomaly detection
so now I'd start zooming in on the
architecture of anomaly detection engine
that we've deployed on-premise on Telus
so anomaly detection is one of the
several analytics use cases running on a
shared multi tenant Hadoop to data Lake
at Telus the end goal of anomaly
detection is crew Ford's want to build
baseline models for subscriber
communication and second to use those
baseline models to identify an omlette
subscriber communication and publish
them downstream during the influencing
stage and then downstream we have
multiple analytics components running
that pickup that pick up these anomalous
anomalous points identified by the
anomaly detection engine and correlate
correlate them with other alerts that we
got about the subscriber who identify a
malicious user behavior so the tech
stack on the left of the slide you see
the text stack that we deploy yep you've
deployed the the anomaly detection
engine on so we've divided the text ID
into three into three swim lanes so at
the bottom you see that we have yarn and
HDFS deployed on physical nodes so we
use yarn for resource orchestration and
resource management we also use yarn and
resource queues for a resource Kota
amongst various cluster tenants we use
HDFS for reliable and distributed
storage and then in the middle swimlane
you see that we deployed spark and
multiple libraries of spark spark or
spark ml spark screaming and the use
part for distributed compute for its
ability to do compute in a distributed
fashion and for stream processing and
batch processing workloads at scale we
also leverage a spark ml quite a bit to
do machine learning at scale both for
training models and for influencing and
then on top you see in the top lane in
the top swimline you see that we have
various spark applications running for
anomaly detection engine on our cluster
we also use plunk for visualization and
dashboards
and with Splunk query language we we
give external teams ability to do ad hoc
queries on the data both raw data and
and detections that reside on our data
late so in this slide you see an
end-to-end architecture pipeline
architecture for the anomaly detection
engine that we have at Telus so the
architecture the part that the
architectural diagram is divided into
three swim lanes
we have ingest at the left then we have
processing swim lane in which we have
multiple spark applications running and
then we have storage where we use HDFS
so what's happening over here is that
the date the the subscriber flow logs is
wrapped up in syslog stream and it's
being streamed to the yarn to to the to
the Hadoop cluster from there on in the
Hadoop cluster we have featured
extraction engine which picks up this
which uses arc streaming to pick up this
data stream it uses a fixed size window
of five minutes to do to create many
batches and then it does additional
processing all those mini batches it
does it does feature extraction it does
feature enrichment and then it does
aggregation and that processed batch is
then written to HDFS for storage and you
can see that in number two in label
number two and then what's happening
downstream is that the modeling engine
essentially picks up that processed
batch and you can see that in number
three and it applies k-means clustering
on it it does distributed k-means
clustering for and build clusters for
user behavior for user behavior
communication behavior and it extracts
other metadata about those clusters as
well it uses cluster mean cluster
variance cluster density and all of that
metadata plus the clusters that we have
identified in this stage are written
into HDFS for storage then downstream
what happens is that you see in the
anomaly detection engine we fetch that
clusters that were identified that were
built by the modeling engine and and
also the batches that were processed by
the future extraction engine we're
features were extracted all like that
those batches and the models are fetched
by the anomaly detection engine and the
anomaly detection engine applies models
to those processed batches to identify
anomalous communication behavior and the
way it identifies anomalous
communication behaviors by taking into
account all the metadata that we
extracted about the cluster we use
cluster centroid we use custom mean
cluster variance cluster density and the
anomalies are a function all of all is a
function of all these parameters and
once the anomalies are identified they
are stored to HDFS and also published
downstream where as I said before the
downstream Analytics components use
those anomalies identified and correlate
them with other alerts for the
subscriber to identify a malicious user
behavior so why did we what prepared us
to use GCP so we are a small team and
what we what we find what we find is
that our time like not only goes into
analytics and to developing
cybersecurity analytics but we're a
quite a bit of time is also spent on
infrastructure troubleshooting
infrastructure management and that's
where we want to leverage GCP GCP
serverless architecture capabilities so
that we can be hands-free from the
infrastructure management and
infrastructure troubleshooting issues
with state-of-the-art services that GCP
provides like data flow and Google
bigquery both of them are certain less
similar services we we want to focus on
our core value prop which is
cybersecurity analytics additionally
Google bigquery is is the state of the
art is a state of the art query engine
it get its blazingly fast on large
amounts of data and it brings a lot of
machine learning capabilities out of the
box so we want to tap into bigquery to
create models for
like to do faster iteration on model
building and that allows us to move at a
fast speed
additionally Google bigquery actually
has a dead simple sequel interface which
a lot of data scientists are familiar
with and that simplifies our port white
a bit and and again like allows us to do
model to do model building at a at a
very fast pace and in the code and the
code that we have because it's sequel
code is easy to maintain as well and it
removes like all the complexity that we
have as a result of spark ml and then
Google by having Google's by having or
data in Google bigquery it enables auto
ml so Auto em will essentially allows
you to build baseline models very quick
and that feature allows us to test our
own machine learning models and
benchmark our own machine like the
performance of our own machine learning
models so and and and and and the
elastic architecture capabilities in
Google in GCP allows us to have a
streamlined resource usage and have a
better cost model for our pipeline so
essentially this is the architecture
that we landed in G's in energy CP pilot
essentially like when you look at it
it's it's very similar with the
architecture that we had on Prem for
anomaly detection engine pipeline there
are still three swim lanes like it's in
jest it's processed and like then just
swimmingly in the process swim lane and
the stores membrane but what we have
done over here is that instead of using
Hadoop Hadoop pools and frameworks we
like like slick spark and and and spark
ml and HDFS we've gone entirely Google
native we're using data flow and beam so
beam is a vendor vendor agnostic
framework we using data flow which is
which is server less be using pub/sub
using cloud storage we using bigquery
bigquery essentially is acting as a data
warehouse for us and and allows us to
search like raw data at really fast
speed also bigquery provides this
machine learning capabilities as I
mentioned and it allows us for faster
model building and simplifies our
machine learning
so with that I'd actually pass on to
Massoud who can discuss the intricacies
of this architecture
all right thanks Abdul okay so if you
look at this end-to-end architectures
let's dig a little bit more so first
thing is you're ingesting trigger so if
you look at the overall ingest
architectures we have two different
sources of data that we're dealing with
one is cloud storage and the other one
is pops up now for production settings
you have to you know somehow need to
pass those data to the storage and the
parser topic either tree fluently
plug-in or you know three CAFTA Connect
now what we did for our POC because we
could not get access to all the
production data because of the sensitive
information we created a tool using open
source java beam which we could simulate
to create twenty fifty thousand messages
per second in a pub sub topic right and
we're gonna get into a little bit more
on details on that but assume now that
we have all the data in a pub sub topic
the second step would be to process and
we have built a dataflow pipeline that
aggregate those data in a fixed window
and then do a batch insert for a
partition table in bigquery if there is
any outliers found we also stream those
data to a different table in bigquery so
that further analysis can be done now a
lot of those logics and you know
everything that's happening within that
process we we pretty much rebuilt it
from scratch if you remember when up to
mention about the spark now this is
actually built on Apache bean
Java SDK with the service architecture
and dollar for honor now the third thing
was so now the data we have it on D
query what he wanted to do is to be able
to see how easily we could train them
and using a bigquery ml came in skinnies
class string model we could easily train
them you know and also to normalize in
terms of how to you know make sure that
it's used in a production environment
what we did is we put all the secure
like statement for for for the q BQ ml
in a stored procedure and you know when
you have used it within scheduled query
within the
now you could literally you know retrain
the data in either ad hoc or also you
know whenever you wanted to use it let's
say every any scheduled manner now
addition to this you also see the cloud
dlp as I say there may there may be some
sensitive information on the log so we
also try to use cloud DLP for for the
deduction for any sensitive information
like IMSI number or subscriber ID we
automated the whole process is in cloud
ill for caed purposes now for the next
few slides what you wanted to go through
some of the challenges we had to
building this architecture so let's take
thing so as I said we needed to find the
tool that we could use to leverage for
simulation and production data load now
if you look at what's inside this data
pipeline it actually uses a open source
json library on right hand side you
could see a json schema that i have and
if you look at this schema that we have
it's very similar to the net flow log
schema so for example you have phase
like subscriber ID source IP destination
IP and for each one of those attribute
is associated with a function so for
example source IP has ipv4 what that
would do is it will generate a random
ipv4 address for source IP now if you
look at a lot of those fields like a
long and integers you could also set up
the range for the sport and you know the
different attributes that we have now
the challenge was when you use that you
know when you use that library within a
data flow pipeline we just need to be
make sure that we have put enough
workers so that we could reach to our
target message per second goal so for
our case what we noticed was you know it
was around 3000 messages per second
palcohol
so we added around 30 and one standard
for workers and it could easily reach
out to that that production volume
there's another challenge that I've just
quickly wanted to mention you know if
you look at this schema it's very random
right but we cannot be completely random
so for example feel like destination IP
we needed to make sure that because
you're going to do a group by on
destination IP so it's
somehow you know we limit the number of
IDs that you know we're going to test it
on so this tool allows us to be very
flexible and create function like submit
or also if you think about you know in
time has to be after that time so those
kind of you know features that could
easily build in so that our data is very
production like so now that we have all
the information or all the data
published on a you know the past
subtopic this is where all the fun
starts we we have built a you know it's
a pretty complex dataflow pipeline
pretty much simulated whatever the logic
that we have on on frame within a week
now one of the challenges we have to
face is how you know how scalable this
would be and how fast we could actually
aggregate those data so if you're
looking at you know the production
volume we're looking at it on twenty
terabyte of data which is a know twenty
fifty thousand s per second translate to
twenty two head of data every day and if
you have a ten minutes window you're
looking at 150 gigabyte of data
accumulated within that period and we
are aggregating those data within so
that it's you know it doesn't have a
system lag in it so the way we did this
is and it's a very simple process by
using you know java beam inbuilt
transform called jason to roll so think
about as we are getting all the Jason
Jason rows we convert them is using an
build function called Jason to draw and
which is really good because now that we
have no object or o tile what you can do
on row is every row is associated with
the schema and it could group by to the
field name of the column name very
easily and also a data aggregated
function to it so for our use case it
was more so you're going to group my
subscriber ID and you're gonna group by
you know the destination subnet and then
you apply aggregate function like mean
max average so if you look at the number
of features that we have it's pretty
much we're educating data in that window
and we're trying to find out what is the
mean max average for transmission
receiving byte what was the duration
what is probably the approximate count
for number of IPs within that time frame
so if you look at on the screen shot we
have
you know you're looking at estimated
size around 11 gigabyte within a very
small window and after aggregation you
could see that it come down to across
the only one gigabyte so the key thing
was that hey it was really scalable and
it was really easy to build you know
such a pipeline without you know just
using the in being transform and you
know let the data flow handling all the
scaling issues for us so let's go to the
next one so now that we have data on you
know we have so we are using a partition
table because it's a you know 20 to the
right data accumulation every day and
the reason we are using de partition
because we don't you know when you
retrain those use those features to
retrain we don't want to go like all the
historical data we probably only care
about the last few days and that's why
we're using the date partition and it
was super simple for us to do you know
just to use the single statement you
could just create a chemins clustering
now that you have your data on a
partition table and you know within 15
minutes we actually trained close to
terabyte scale data and it's completely
segmented with different cluster and it
also allows us to evaluate so for
example we wanted to try out right out
with different number of cluster was the
DB index looks like and we found our
sweet spot was number of cluster when it
when it's used with the 4 so now the
data is segmented we're actually not
done yet we had to do a little bit of
normalization right now the way we did
normalization so now think about all the
similar you know the central cluster
rehab if we went through each cluster
and find all those points and using
standard deviation function we just
created a normalized distance now that
is the normalized distance that we're
going to use later for you know outlet
prediction online prediction now another
challenge for this one was you know how
soon you're going to retrain right so we
using a schedule query along with the
stored procedure multi statements equal
support we just saved the query and read
on when he when he wanted it to me and
we could also do the version control so
that you know if you wanted to change
some schema or change some you know the
features we could easily do that as well
so let's go to the next one so now that
we have our normalized data what we did
is so for bigquery ml one of the things
that you have to know that you could
actually input it as a tensile model
right and you couldn't put it on a GCS
market we use a very similar approach
you know what we did is we directly
Cooley our normalize table from data
flow when it stands up and use it as a
side input so now that we have those
normalize the information available and
side input only operates within those
you know the ten minutes of five minutes
windy a great aggregation window that we
have so it's going to be refreshed
automatically as our pipeline process
data so if you recreated a model you
have an anonymous normalized factors
it's you know data flow pipe nation
should be able to see it but they're
actually doing any downtime or on or
restart now how we are actually doing
the outlier detection and it's a
two-step process we used Apache Commons
map functions just you know some
distance calculating distance function
that we could easily leverage so the
step one was we needed to find out you
know now that we're getting are all the
input vectors data so step one was to
find out who is the closest centroid
right which is the closest centroid for
this input vector once we know that
centroid information based on the
normalized distance that we have
calculated earlier we we put it together
we put them in a you know a standard
scoring system and if it's a three
standard deviation above mean or two
standard deviation above mean we know
that that could be a good candidate for
outlier so if you look at the you know
the diagram I have on the right hand
side so we have three different clusters
showing and you could see that there's
one point which is way further than our
center point or the you know the
standard deviation distance but there's
also a normal point which is within the
boundary right so that's how we know if
it's an outlier or not now finding a
single outlier may not be enough we are
trying to look for a pattern of outliers
to be able to see that hey there may be
something going on in terms of security
now the another screenshot that I have
right now so you could see that you know
for the feature extraction it's really
great
so we extruded the features and we're
doing going through the DLP transform
and then we
a batch insert or partition table but
with the same feature extract also
branched out to our anomaly detection
transform which is getting all the
normalize data as a side input and then
you know within the anomaly detection
we're doing those two operation that I
just mentioned and then we stream those
data if found we string those data true
to outlier table
hoping that hey someone's going to start
looking at them and to find the hey if
it's really a risk or not okay so in
summary you see we have built an
end-to-end service animal detection
solution is less than a full weeks that
successfully process 250,000 events per
second using gala flow which comes down
to around 20 terabyte of data daily
accumulation of data we have trained and
evaluated a terabyte skills data by
school advice by using the Coulee ml in
less than 15 minutes and found outliers
in near real-time if you're more
interested to learn about the solution
please check out the github link in here
hopefully you find this talk useful and
thanks for listening in